- Hello Internet, how's it goin'?
- Hello there, this is
a Slow Mo Guys video.
You can expect to see
high levels of slow mo
and also high levels of funk.
- And guys?
- And guys, yeah.
What we've got here is a standard
procedure 1980s Sony hifi
which has been in my
life for my entire life
and I'm sick of lookin'
at it to be honest.
You know, nobody uses it.
So we messed up one of the speakers,
took the front off.
We're gonna tip it on its back
and put in a lovely selection.
Dan's just rewinding a tape.
We're gonna put in a
lovely selection of paint.
Dan, hit the funk.
- For copyright reasons,
you will not be hearing
the song we're dancin' to
but I'll play it anyway.
- We'll replace it with
something equally good.
- [Dan] That's not too good.
- [Gavin] I've never seen such a nice,
new fresh can of paint ruined so fast.
Look at that.
- Immediately ruined.
This is expensive paint.
- [Gavin] It's a shame,
how much is that paint?
- Like 18 quid a pot.
- [Gavin] Bloody hell!
Why didn't you get craft paint
or somethin' like kids paint?
- Well, sorry, jeez.
- [Gavin] Bloody premium house paint.
- Just for this.
- [Gavin] All right, I'm
gonna turn the volume up
all the way to, no, there's no 11.
Yep.
Gonna get some predictive focus on the go.
- [Dan] Predictive focus.
- 'Cause when I focus on the actual paint
it's gonna immediately go out of focus
so I'm gonna focus about here
so that as the droplets
are at their apex.
- [Dan] Good word, good word.
- Yeah?
It's gonna be in focus.
All right, ram it.
- [Dan] Yeah?
- [Gavin] Yeah.
That was good.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- [Gavin] All right, have
a look at the playback.
- [Dan] Okay, let's go.
Oh, you can see the speaker start to move.
Oh wow!
That is awesome.
I like how the green is moving
'cause it's the wateriest
and the orange isn't movin' yet.
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- [Dan] That is awesome.
- [Gavin] So it seems as
though the more watery colors,
they're the ones that bounce first.
- Yeah, this time I've tried to mix 'em up
so they're all kind of equally watery
and I think they're all
gonna mix in together
once it starts really goin' for it.
- All right, I've got a macro lens on now
so we're really close.
We're gonna clear this
out and put new color in
and I wanna get those
initial blobs of paint
just as they rise up to the top
'cause they look kinda marbly and cool.
- [Dan] Okay, what,
just above the speaker?
- [Gavin] Just above the speaker yeah.
- [Dan] It's the perfect
wateriness now isn't it?
I've mastered this.
Okay, okay.
Ready?
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- [Dan] Go.
- [Gavin] That was good.
- [Dan] Good.
- Oh, that's bright.
I bet you thought the video was over,
well it isn't, because right
now I'm gonna do an ad.
Are you ready for the ad?
Wait for it.
Here's the ad.
This video was brought to by Audible.
Bet you didn't even
notice, that was seamless.
Obviously you know now.
Audible is top because
you get a free book.
You sign up, you get a
free audiobook sample
and even if you don't keep the membership,
you get to keep the book.
I recommend it.
There's over 100,000 books.
What, you want my opinion
on which book to get?
Okay, "Game of Thrones", solid choice.
Bloody good TV show, bloody good book.
And the audiobook is cool
'cause you get all the voices
read to you in your ear.
Got me through some pretty
severe plane journeys as well
'cause it's really long.
So, if you want one, you want a free book,
free audiobook, go to audible.com/slowmo.
Dead easy.
All right, well, that's pretty much it.
That actually is the end of the video now.
There's nothing after this.
My advice on what to do next,
probably just turn the video off.
Turn it off, just click
it out, do somethin' else.
You could subscribe if you want.
You can subscribe for more slow mo videos.
If you've already seen them all
then just wait and the
next one will come out
in like a month or somethin'.